It is the best-selling book in history.
No volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted. And its words,
sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious, should always be studied
carefully. It is the Bible, the word of
God. Welcome to Bible Answers Live,
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions.
This broadcast is a previously recorded
episode. To receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast,
call 800-835-6747.
Once again, that's 800-835-6747.
Now, here's your host from Amazing Facts
International, Pastor Doug Batchelor.
Welcome, friends, to Bible Answers Live.
Would you like to hear an amazing fact?
All right, listen up.
About 4 hours north of Sydney, in
Australia, in a national park, a fire is
smoldering out of control, and it's been
doing so for thousands of years.
Known as Burning Mountain, the
mysterious underground blaze is the
oldest known continuous fire on the
planet.
Located under Mount Wingen, in the state
of New South Wales, Wingen means fire in
the language of the local Aborigines.
This underground smolder is a coal seam
fire, one of thousands burning around
the globe.
Once ignited, these subterranean fires
are almost impossible to put out.
Slowly, but intensely, they travel like
a burning fuse through the coal seam,
which is a layer of coal that naturally
occurs beneath the earth's surface.
No one knows whether it was humans or
lightning that first ignited the Mount
fire, though Mount Wingen fire. Experts
estimate the fire is about the size of a
ball, 20 to 30 ft in diameter, about 100
ft underground, and it reaches
temperatures of 1,800° Fahrenheit.
Because the fire lacks adequate
ventilation, it burns very slowly,
advancing at a speed of about 3 ft per
year.
More like embers in a barbecue than a
typical coal fire.
If you visit the national park, only
current evidence that you'll see now is
some smoke and white ash, ground that's
warm to the touch, barren red rocks void
of plants, and a sulfuric smell emitted
as the fire below cooks the minerals of
the mountain.
You know, friends, there are many
Christians that believe that God has an
eternal place of burning, and we're
going to talk about that tonight on
Bible Answers Live. We're so glad that
you're here, and you're going to
hopefully participate, tell your friends
to participate, calling with your Bible
questions. Pastor Ross is off tonight,
so I, along with our engineering team in
the studio, we're going to be taking
your live Bible questions. And before we
do, we're going to have prayer, as we
always do.
Loving Lord, we thank you so much for
your goodness and blessings. We thank
you for the blessed book the Bible, that
guides us. You've said that thy word is
truth, Lord, and we pray that the truth
will set us free. Be with us tonight in
every aspect of this program. We pray in
Jesus' name.
Amen.
So, if you have any Bible questions,
either on the subject I just mentioned,
or on any Bible topic we're talking
about living the Christian life, give us
a call. Here's the phone number, 800 God
says. That's 800 463-7297.
Let me say it again for those who may be
driving, 800-463-7297
with your Bible questions. We also do
offer sometimes free offers. Well, not
sometimes, every program we offer free
offers, and that's a different number
that takes you to operators that will
take your request for the free Bible
study material.
Now, I asked the question, there are
many Christians that believe that God
has a place of eternal burning.
Um
does the Bible teach that? We got a
lesson that's going to talk about that
tonight. It's called Is the Devil in
Charge of Hell?
Is the Devil in charge of Hell? But let
me give you just a couple of uh verses
that address that subject.
There are two extremes when it comes to
the subject of Hell.
One extreme is some people say there is
no punishment of the wicked, and some
believe everyone's going to be saved,
sort of a universalism.
Then there's those who have people
writhing in sulfur and brimstone through
endless ages, and a billion years go by
and they're still screaming in agony,
burning all over their bodies, and
they've only begun after a billion
years. Just imagine burning through
eternity.
Then there's the Bible teaching
that the wicked are cast into the lake
of fire and burnt up.
Every man is punished according to what
he deserves, but they're ultimately
consumed. The Bible says that the fire
comes down out of Heaven, Revelation
chapter 2, and it devours them. They are
consumed. Look at the Malachi chapter 4,
verse 1.
For behold, the day comes as an oven.
And the proud, yes, all who do wickedly,
the proud and the wicked, will be
stubble. And the day that is coming will
burn them up, says the Lord. It'll leave
them neither root nor branch. Saying
that the root, the branch, burnt up, the
wicked are stubble, they're devoured.
The Bible tells us the meek will inherit
the earth. The saved are not going to be
looking at a torture chamber through
eternity of lost people barbecuing, if
you will.
And uh there is a place where the wicked
are burnt. Jesus is clear.
He says that um
don't fear him who can destroy the body,
but he can't touch your soul, but fear
him who can destroy soul and body in
Hell. So, both the body and the soul are
ultimately destroyed in the lake of
fire. People are going to be punished
according to what they deserve,
and there are varying works, not only
for the wicked, there are varying
rewards, I should say, not only for the
wicked, but for the righteous.
If you want to know more about that
subject and what the Bible actually
teaches, then this lesson is filled with
scripture. They're going to put that up
on the screen for you again. It's called
Is the Devil in Charge of Hell? If you
want a copy of that, then you can call
our resource number, 800-835-6747.
800-835-6747.
Uh we are broadcasting tonight not only
on Amazing Facts Television, we are on
the Amazing Facts Facebook page, the
YouTube page, the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page,
and uh you can watch as well as listen.
And uh again, call in with your
questions, 800 463-7297
With that, I see that there we got a
couple people that have called in. We
have some lines open. Great time to call
in with your Bible questions.
And we're going to talk to um
Daryl, who is calling from Arizona. I
clicked it, there he is. Daryl, you're
on the air with Bible Answers Live.
Can you hear me?
Daryl?
Let me see, I'll try that one more time.
Daryl, there you are. Okay.
And your question tonight?
Yeah.
Yeah, my question is
if Eve conceived
once in chapter 4, Mhm. and verse two
one and two,
it doesn't that infer that
Abel was a twin
to
Cain?
You know, I've heard people say that,
but it doesn't always give the um
it doesn't always give the age of the
second-born. For example, it tells us
that Noah had Shem, Ham, and Japheth,
and it doesn't imply they're triplets.
Typically in the Bible, in the case of
like Perez and Zerah, or Jacob and Esau,
it tells you when they're twins.
And so, because Cain is mentioned first
and it says the Lord has given me a man
child, I think he was the firstborn.
Abel was his younger brother, he came
second.
Yeah, even in the case if he was a twin,
he would be the younger brother and came
second. Well, technically, you're right.
That That's true. I But um usually if if
uh
they had twins, it's hard to imagine
twins are rare. It's kind of hard to
imagine that Eve's first child would be
twins.
Well, and
But they were talked about
But when when she names Cain, she kind
of names him exclusively, I've gotten a
man of from the Lord, she says. And so,
she's treating it like an individual
event.
So, I don't think they were twins, but
they certainly were brothers, and of
course, that was very sad that uh Cain
rose up and took his brother's life.
And the Bible says the blood of Abel,
his brother, cried to the Lord. When
Jesus, when he talked about the
punishment that was coming on Jerusalem,
he said, "The blood
of righteous Abel, all the way to the
blood of Zechariah, the son of
Berechiah, will be demanded of that
generation."
So, um there is vengeance that comes
from God when innocent blood is spilled.
All right, we're going to talk to
Anthony, and that frees up another line.
Again, if you want to call in with your
Bible questions, that number 800 God
says, 800-463-7297.
Anthony is calling from New York.
Anthony, you're on the air.
Uh good evening, Pastor Doug. Evening.
As I If you don't have enough callers, I
have a whole list of questions, if you
Well, let's start with the first one and
see how we go.
Yes, for sure. Um
So, my question um
is uh it's based on two verses, Genesis
You said go ahead. is the first one. And
Yeah, and the Lord God said, "Behold,
the man has become as one of us, to know
good and evil.
And now, lest he put forth his hand and
take also of the tree of life and eat,
and the key part that I want to focus
on, and live forever."
And then the second verse is 1
Corinthians chapter 15 verse 53
where it says for this corruptible must
put on incorruption and this mortal must
put on immortality.
And so my question is, what is the
purpose of this tree of life that it was
talking about in Genesis chapter 3?
Uh what is the purpose of the tree of
life in heaven if we're going to be
immortal? You know, that's a great
question. Um
some people say, well, it sounds like
that the tree itself has something to do
with our living forever.
And yet
so many other scriptures, you mentioned
one in 1 Corinthians, sound like eternal
life is a gift that God just weaves into
our very being in the um
in the new earth.
And in the, you know, resurrection. So
do if we fail to eat from the tree of
life, will we begin to atrophy and
ultimately die?
Um
you know, it almost makes it sound like
that that the tree of life in in one
sense is going to be a symbol of Jesus
and through believing in Jesus and
accepting him
we have eternal life.
Christ is
you know, he died on a tree.
And he says, my body is food and my
blood is drink. Now, not that, you know,
we're little literally to turn into
cannibals, but
uh Christ is the tree of life.
And so I think that that when we eat
from the fruit of the tree of life,
it'll probably be vitalizing in some
way. But I think eternal life is a gift
that God gives us ultimately.
And if we happen to get stuck in some
far corner of the cosmos and couldn't
get back to the tree, I don't think we'd
die.
I think that God sustains us.
So
hopefully that makes sense. You know,
now I'm delving into some of the
mysteries.
Uh do you have uh one more quick
question, Anthony?
Yes, uh this one is quick. Um you know,
you hear quips and quotes a lot of times
that we say was not really in the Bible.
Uh we hear this uh quote that says uh
God helps those that helps themselves.
Is that biblical?
Well, that's actually a quote from
Benjamin Franklin.
Um I do think it's biblical. It is a
biblical truth in that, you know, God
will tell us what to do. And as we make
an effort, as we make a human effort to
do what God tells us to do, he then
works miracles.
So
I know an old uh Christian that used to
say, "The harder I work, the luckier I
get."
And of course, he he's teasing saying
that actually putting in human effort
makes you successful.
Um God told the disciples, "I want you
to cross the Sea of Galilee."
And they were rowing
and they came into a storm and they they
weren't making any progress. And the
Bible says that Jesus came to them while
they were rowing. So they were doing
what they could humanly do and then he
got in the boat and instantly, John
chapter 6, they were at their
destination. So I do think that um
uh the Lord blesses tenacity. The Lord
blesses diligence. There's Proverbs that
talk about that.
So the principle is true even though
that statement is actually Ben Franklin
from Poor Richard's Almanac.
Hey, thank you, Anthony. Appreciate your
questions.
And that does open another line. If you
have a Bible question, 800-463-7297.
Just before we go to our next call,
quick announcement, friends. Something
very exciting is coming up this weekend.
We're going to be broadcasting from the
Amazing Facts World Center a special
series dealing with Revelation chapter
14, what they call the three angels'
messages. And that's what goes to the
world just before Jesus returns. In
Revelation 14, he's pictured coming in
the clouds. Just before he comes in the
clouds, there's these three angelic
messages that go to the world. We are
having a weekend symposium and Amazing
Facts Summit and it's called
Revelation's Final Warning. And if you'd
like to participate in that, it'll be
streaming online. It'll be on Amazing
Facts Television. And it's going to be
January 16, 17, and 18. And we encourage
you I'm sorry, January 14 through 16.
January 14 through 16. It'll be Friday,
Saturday, and Sunday.
And uh a number of special speakers are
going to be there. Uh myself and uh
several others. Pastor Ross, Carlos
Muñoz, John Lomacang, Dwayne Lemon,
Daniel Hudgens.
And they're going to be taking these
different aspects of the three angels'
message. You will be inspired. If you're
looking for something to revive and
inspire you then
go to the Amazing Facts website. You'll
find more information on how you can
either attend in person
to hear at the World Center in Northern
California or you can watch online. And
so be look up that information on
Revelation's Final Warning. All right,
with that we're going to go to Michael.
Thank you for your patience, Michael.
You're on the air with Bible Answers
Live.
Hello, Pastor Doug. Thanks for taking my
question. Yes, sir.
My question uh is regarding Daniel's the
kingdoms of Daniel 6:26 and 2:44.
And if those are the same, will will the
kingdom of Daniel 2:44 last until the
end? Will it also last until the end
without being destroyed? Well, in Daniel
6, we're talking about Daniel in the
lions' den.
And so you did you mean Daniel 6?
Yeah, 6:26. Okay, so that's talking
about let me go here real quick. Um
yeah, and this is the kingdom of Persia.
That is not the last kingdom that you
find mentioned in Daniel.
Well
the kingdom of God is in Daniel 6:26.
And I make a decree that in every
dominion of my kingdom, this is Darius'
decree. He's a king of Persia,
Medo-Persia. He says, "I make a decree
that in every dominion of my kingdom,
men must tremble and fear before the God
of Daniel, for he is the living God."
Oh, I see what you're talking about,
yeah. And steadfast forever, his kingdom
is the one that will not be destroyed.
His dominion shall endure to the end.
That kingdom, yes, is the God's kingdom
that lasts forever.
Yeah, and if that's same as Daniel 2:44,
will Daniel 2:44 also last until the end
without being destroyed?
Well, it's Christ's kingdom is the one,
yeah, that's the same kingdom.
I'm reading Daniel 2:44. And in the days
of these kings, God will set up a
kingdom that will never be destroyed.
So the kingdom that does not fall is
God's kingdom. It'll last forever.
Right. It sounds like when it says it'll
last until the end that it's a
contemporaneous kingdom to uh
Nebuchadnezzar and King Darius and that
it will last forever and not be
destroyed.
Yeah, so you'll see you're actually onto
the main theme of the book of Daniel.
You can see in Daniel chapter 2, in
Daniel chapter 3,
in Daniel chapter 4.
I'm doing it in my mind right now.
Daniel chapter 5 with Belshazzar's
feast, Daniel 6, Daniel in the lions'
den, Daniel 7 with the visions of the um
the lion and the bear.
And uh the leopard and then you go to
Daniel 8 where you got the vision of the
goat and the ram. All of those visions
talk about the kingdom.
And it's the earthly kingdoms that are
at war with God's kingdom.
It's kind of like the curse that you see
happening there in in Genesis chapter 3
where it talks about the
the um enmity that it would exist
between the serpent, the kingdoms of
this world, and the woman, Mhm. God's
church.
But yeah, and it ultimately the message
of Daniel is that God's kingdom will
destroy every other kingdom.
Well, I thank you for that and we do
have a um
we've got a study guide on Daniel
chapter 6 and Daniel chapter 2.
If you uh look in the Historicals of
Prophecy, we've got one called The
Millennial Man that talks about those
earthly kingdoms.
Thank you, Michael. We're going to move
on here and talk next to um
David calling from California somewhere.
David, you're on the air with Bible
Answers Live.
Good evening, Pastor Doug. Evening. My
question My question is
when Mary birthed Jesus
did he receive her DNA?
So if you had poked Jesus in the finger
with a pin, he would bleed and I expect
that his blood would have had
um testimony
that um he was related to Mary
physically.
I think so. Yeah, because Jesus, you
know, as a baby, it says he became a
man.
He was born and there as a fetus, as he
grew in her womb, he was receiving blood
and nourishment from her body. There
would have been evidence. Now, you know,
they say in DNA, you got your
mitochondrial DNA, the mother's DNA.
The question would be, what would the
father's DNA have looked like?
So um that's something of a mystery.
But yeah, you
It is. he def- definitely had uh
uh I, you know, he was human. I think he
probably had some
Thank you. visual similarities to Mary
as well.
Thanks for your question, David.
Appreciate your patience. And uh talking
next with Wayne. Wayne is calling from
Idaho. You're on the air with Bible
Answers Live.
Thanks, Pastor Doug.
Thank you.
Um looking at Genesis 20 and I'm seeing
where Abraham and Sarah
lied to Abimelech
and I said, "Tell her, you know, tell
him that you're my sister so I will be
spared." Yes.
Um verse 16 after it's all said and done
and and God has revealed to him
Abimelech says that uh in verse 16
that
since I have given thy brother a
thousand pieces of silver, behold, he is
to thee a covering of the eyes
unto all that are with thee. What does
that mean?
Yeah, and I think some versions say a
veil.
Uh Abimelech is he's being a little
sarcastic. You see, Abraham
he's supposed to have this great faith
in God and yet he doesn't trust that
God's going to protect him from the the
Philistines.
And he said, "Your sister
he was he by this point he knows that
she's his wife.
And so he says, "Your sister
um and then he says that this will be a
veil. Now, when a woman was unmarried,
she was supposed to wear a veil.
And uh
when Sarah went to dwell among the
Philistines, I'm not so sure that she
was veiled. He says, "Look, if you don't
if you're worried about if you're
worried about other men looking at her
and thinking she's so beautiful they're
going to kill you for your wife maybe
you should put a veil on her."
So, there's I think there's sort of a
little sarcastic message that Abimelech
is telling Abraham in this. It's funny
you should mention this. I just I read
through the Bible every year. I read
this story this morning.
So, um
Yeah, it's
Yeah, exactly. It's it was fresh in my
mind.
Hey, thanks so much, Wayne. Appreciate
your question.
You have a good night. Bye-bye. All
right, we're going to talk next with
Austin. Austin from North Carolina,
you're on the air with Bible Answers
Live.
Oh, hello, Pastor Doug. So nice to speak
with you. Sure missing Pastor Ross. Yes,
I will.
I'll pass that on. I'll let him know.
My question um is about Genesis chapter
9 ch- um
verses 22 through 27. Mhm. Um I
understand um the the brothers
um
that uh you know, Noah's sons, the sons
of Noah is Ham, Shem, and Japheth and
then Ham had a son Canaan. And I know
there was an incident where
the
um
uh
the the first brother uh Ham went in and
saw his father uncovered and he came out
and then the other guys went in and
I'm I'm I'm guessing that it's because
they turned away with respect that they
were you know, proper in that. My
question really, Pastor, is
uh verse 27 when um
it talks about how
um Canaan
is the one um gets cursed be Canaan and
he would be the servant to all the
brothers and I'm just I just don't
understand why he as the son he's not
mentioned as doing anything at all in
the story and I know we're not supposed
to have the sins of our fathers, right?
So, that was confusing to me. Yeah. You
know, evidently what happened it says
Noah drank wine and he became
intoxicated. I'm not sure that they
understood the full effects of what that
would do back then.
And he was stumbling around in his tent
and he was naked.
Ham went in probably with his son
who would have been younger.
And uh you know, at this point they had
had uh been out of the ark for some time
cuz Noah is now farming.
And um
and Ham instead of saying, "Oh, this
isn't good. Let's cover grandpa up."
They walk out of the tent and
Canaan begins to mock grandpa that was
stumbling around drunk and showing great
disrespect for you know, his elders.
And so um a curse came from Noah upon
Ham and his descendant Canaan who I
think was with his father when he went
in.
So, or his father maybe came out and
told Canaan what happened and Canaan
began to mock him among the the clan and
the tribe.
So, um
uh the curse fell on him.
that, Pastor? How do you like how would
I have learned that without asking you,
I mean? Well, I I didn't get it through
a dream. I actually read commentaries
and some other good Bible scholars.
Yeah, they you look in some and they're
free. Many of them are free now. You can
go online and you type in this verse and
you'll see some of the great
commentaries of the Protestant
reformers. These guys read Hebrew,
Greek, and Latin and they'll also read
you know, some of the other Hebrew
writers give additional insight on these
things.
Cuz some of it is cultural. They
understood that um it would only have
mentioned Ham, but Canaan must have
participated in the bad behavior.
Thank you so very much. Now I can move
on. All right, good. Sounds like you're
reading through your Bible.
That's right. All right, good for you.
so much, Pastor. Thank you, Austin.
Appreciate your question. And uh yeah,
if you want to call in with your Bible
questions, we still got to the best part
of the program to go. Call 800-463-7297.
800-463-7297.
All right, we're going to talk next with
Lynn who's calling from Pennsylvania.
Lynn, you're on the air with Bible
Answers Live.
Well, hello, Pastor Doug. Hi.
There's something that's got my
curiosity going for quite a while. Um
when you read Revelation chapter 4
verse 2
and 3
and then you go on and you read
Revelation chapter 5 1 all the way
through 7. Mhm. My question is when John
is taken up um by the spirit into heaven
and he sees on the throne
um having one that sits in
sat on the throne and he described them.
Then I'm thinking is you supposedly
nobody has ever seen God the Father.
Mhm. But then it says in chapter 5 that
the one that sits on the throne has the
book
written and then how John weeps because
um
No man can open the book.
was found worthy, right? And then he
hands the book to
um
the lamb.
So, is that the Father God the Father
that John is seeing in this vision or
and then he does see Jesus take the
from the right hand
of he who sits on the throne. So, that
would be God the Father and Jesus,
wouldn't it? Yep, I think it is God the
Father, but you notice um I don't think
he's seeing the full glory of God's face
there.
Moses asked, he said, "Lord, can I see
your glory?" God says, "Yes, I'll I'll
let you see my glory, but you can't look
on my face and live."
And so I you know, when God gave the 10
Commandments on Mount Sinai
um Yes. his glory was veiled in thunder
and clouds and no man could look upon
it.
So, and then the Bible says no man has
seen the Father. Now, we will ultimately
see God cuz one of the last things it
says in Revelation, it says and we will
see his face.
Blessed are you know, blessed are the
pure in in spirit, they will see.
Blessed are the pure in heart, they will
see God.
In our sinful condition, we can't do
that. And keep in mind, John is seeing
these things in vision.
He's probably not literal. So, you know,
the Lord may have veiled or blurred the
glory of God to some extent so he could
see it, but that must have been God the
Father cuz you then you he's giving the
book to God the Son.
Right. And he describes oh, so he must
be describing the throne and not cuz
cuz he said that
he that sat
was to look upon like jasper. Yeah. Now,
do you know if you look in Daniel
chapter 7 and we're going to have to cut
off our break here in just a minute but
I just want you to notice, Lynn, that in
Daniel 7 it talks about the Father and
the Son. It says, "I saw one like the
Ancient of Days." And then you go to
verse 11 and one like the Son of Man
comes before him.
So, um
yeah, sorry, verse 13. I was watching to
behold one like the Son of Man came
before him. So, Revelation is very much
like an echo of the book of Daniel. So,
you're seeing both there. Thank you,
Lynn, very much for your question. And
uh listening friends, we're going to be
back in just a moment. I want to remind
you that we are having a special program
beginning this Friday evening. It'll go
January 14th through the 16th called
Revelation's Final Warning. And if you'd
like to participate in that, all you've
got to do is go to the Amazing Facts
website. You'll see a banner there talks
about Revelation's Final Warning.
And um
you can participate in that program
and help the person in your area or you
can view it online amazingfacts.tv or
Facebook page. Taking our mid-term
break, so to speak. We'll be back with
questions for you.
We are back, listening friends, to Bible
Answers Live and uh we're going to go
back to the phones here and take some
questions. Talking next with E Frank.
E Frank, you're on the air with Bible
Answers Live.
Yes, uh good evening, Pastor Doug. Uh I
have a question that is always on my
mind. This has to do with uh uh
individuals, a person that I know who
was um
uh involved with uh
uh is Satanism.
She was a person that it it said that
she was consecrated to Jesus and so she
could not get out of her
satanic uh
cult because uh her father was a
descendant of other Satanists and so
she she also informed me that she owned
stock in the 19th century from a um
uh
what they call a um
a railway company here in New York City
in the borough of Queens. So, uh
I I told her, "Why do you tell me that
you're consecrated to Christ and you do
not leave if you were consecrated to
Christ?" And she told me also that her
grandmother baptized her in
Christianity. Now, my question for you,
Pastor Doug, is can a person who's that
way
leave the cult and automatically not
lose their soul or their life and become
consecrated to Christ and become a
born-again Christian and be a
Bible-believing person?
Yeah, you know, sometimes people think
because uh you know, my my parents were
into Satanism or you were part of a cult
or you I you know, when I was a kid
in our family, my mother was in show
business and a lot of her friends were
into the occult and we used Ouija boards
and they were into astrology and and all
kinds of things that are unbiblical, but
you know, when you seek after God,
you're you're born again. All old things
pass away and all things are made new.
So, we don't need to worry about that.
So, I want to let anything like that
from the past concern you.
And once a person has accepted Jesus,
then
Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before. The Bible
Answers Live is produced by Amazing
Facts International, a faith-based
ministry located in Granite Bay,
California.
All right.
We we are still on the air, friends. I
don't know what that was all about.
All right, friends. We're going to go to
Hopefully that helps you, Frank, with
your question. Talking to David in New
Jersey. David,
and you're welcome to the Bible Answers
Live program.
Good morning or afternoon or whatever
time it is. I'm I'm truck driving in I'm
in New Jersey. I'm from Virginia. But,
uh it's so good and happy to talk with
you, Pastor Doug. And I was I was hoping
to talk to Pastor Ross, too, but he's
not there, so. You'll have to call
another time, too.
Exactly. Exactly. I just wanted to say
uh thank you for your ministry and uh I
became a Christian through your ministry
and watching your
uh
um
seminar prophecy seminars.
Uh so, I'm very happy.
So,
I hear the music now.
All right. Well,
yeah. Your question now.
Okay. My question is
basically we'll be protected through the
tribulations.
Through those verses. Is that correct?
Well, let me read this for our friends
who are listening.
It says that
Yeah. It says you'll not be afraid of
the terror by night nor the arrow that
flies by day, nor of the pestilence.
That word pestilence means plague, that
walks in darkness, nor the destruction
that lays waste at noonday. A thousand
may fall at your side and 10,000 at your
right hand, but it shall not come near
you. Only with your eyes will you look
and see the reward of the wicked.
Because you've made the Lord, who is my
refuge, even the most high, your
dwelling place. No evil will befall you,
nor shall any plague come nigh your
dwelling.
And so, God protected the children of
Israel
when the plagues fell on Egypt. He will
protect us when the seven last plagues
fall that are described in Revelation 15
and 16.
And so, yes, I believe that this is a
promise we can claim.
Now, that does not mean Some people
might think, well, does Pastor Doug does
that mean that
uh I never need to take any health
precautions if there's a a um
pandemic in the world. So, this is not a
verse for that. You know, the Bible says
don't tempt the Lord. So, if there's
something you can do to keep yourself
healthy, keep yourself healthy.
But, when the seven last plagues fall,
these supernatural
um plagues from God,
uh he promises to protect his people
during that time.
Yeah. Verse 11 says, you know, the
angels will take charge over us. Yes.
He'll give his angels charge over you to
keep you in all your ways.
Yes.
Yes. Yes.
Yeah. That's right.
So,
Okay. That's great. That's That's what I
wanted to confirm. And you did. Well,
thank you. Yeah.
God bless. Good to talk with you, David.
And be safe on the road.
Thank you, sir. Bye-bye.
All right. Let's see here. Uh we're
going to talk with uh Jemima, who's
calling from Canada. Am I saying that
right?
Or is it Jemima? That's right. Yes. And
your question? Yeah.
Hi, Pastor Doug. I just wanted to know
that I was so blessed by the um previous
uh ministry that you have, the Panorama
Prophecy. And um
I I understand become I understand more
about the Bible and yeah, it's so nice,
Pastor Doug. I watch from the beginning
till the end.
Anyway, um thank you all for your
ministry. And anyway, um my question uh
Pastor Doug is from the book of
Proverbs.
It's um
uh
verse 26. So, it says here, while as yet
he had not made the earth,
Now, you're in Proverbs chapter 8.
And what verse?
8 verse
Seven. Sorry. Yeah. 26 to No, 22 to
30, actually. But, I was um little bit
um like confusion here. It says verse
27, when he prepared the heavens,
he set a compass upon the face of the
face of the
So, my question, Pastor Doug, is that
mean that um if this mean that we were
angels before? Like when even when God
created us, what like where are we? And
it says also here from
I am
because somebody like, you know,
somebody had like a do um Bible study
with me and they they were teaching this
um I already was born like Solomon says
and he was in the kingdom of heaven. And
they said that we were angels.
No. Yeah. No, we
We were never angels before. Let me just
give you something to think about,
Jemima. When you go to the beginning of
chapter 8,
chapter 8 is a beautiful soliloquy. It's
like a poem of wisdom. These are
Proverbs. This is not a doctrinal
discourse. It says, does wisdom cry out?
Of course, wisdom doesn't cry. So,
wisdom's not a person.
And understanding lift up her voice. She
takes her stand on the top of the hill.
Everything it's saying here is talking
about wisdom and it's using all of these
allegories and analogies. It has nothing
to do with people being born. It's
saying wisdom was there with God in the
very beginning when he formed the earth.
And that's what you're reading there
from verse 27.
When he prepared the heavens, I, wisdom,
was there. When he drew a circle on the
face of the deep. When he established
the clouds above. When he strengthened
the fountains of the deep. When he
assigned to the sea its limit, so the
waters would not transgress his command.
When he marked the foundations of the
earth, then I, wisdom, was beside him as
a master craftsman. And I, against
beginning of wisdom, was daily his
delight, rejoicing always before him.
It's all a poem about wisdom, if you
read from the beginning of this chapter.
So, the idea that this is saying that we
had a preexistence
is totally unbiblical. And I'd be very
careful about people you're studying
with that say that you existed before
you were born. That's almost like
teaching a form of reincarnation.
And uh that's that's a very unbiblical
teaching. Thank you, Jemima. And I
You know, if you want to know more about
that,
we have a lesson that talks about um
death.
And the lesson on death will actually
talk about preexistence a little bit.
So, if you want to know more of that
about that, we have a lesson called Are
the Dead Really Dead? And we'll send you
a free copy of that. That is resource
number 800 835-6747.
All right. Thanks for Jemima's call and
we're going to talk to um
Let me see here.
All right. Gibson in Australia. Gibson,
you're on the air with Bible Answers
Live.
Uh thank you. How are you, Doc? Doing
really well.
Thanks. Uh thank you for taking my
question.
Um so, my question is just in relation
to Acts 2:17.
Um so, would you like me to read that to
you? Sure.
Uh yep. Um and it shall come to pass in
the last days, says God, that I will
pour out my spirit on all flesh. Uh your
son and your daughter shall prophesy.
Your young men shall see visions.
And your old men shall dream dreams.
Mhm.
So, my question is just um does
does sort of the Satan have the power
um to to give people dreams? Um and are
there any examples cuz I know throughout
the Bible there's always examples of God
appearing to people in dreams and the
angels appearing to people.
Um so, I was just wondering if Satan can
do that as well. Yeah, I think that most
people listening, I'm expecting Gibson,
you've had this experience where you
have something called a nightmare.
And um
I think that in the book of Job, and you
know, I remember reading it. I'm trying
to remember. It talks about when the
hair stood up on the on my flesh and a
being went by.
Oh, you see. Yeah, you're acquainted
with it. But, it seems like one of the
one of the speakers in the book of Job
talks about what is a nightmare-like
experience.
And even in Genesis, it says that a
horror of darkness came on Abraham.
So, um God can certainly influence
dreams.
The devil If the devil can tempt us, he
can probably influence our dreams. He
can put suggestions in our minds. We
know that.
And sometimes our dreams, most of the
time our dreams are not God or the
devil. Most of the time our dreams are
our brain simply uh rebooting, so to
speak. And um you'll be dreaming about
the the things that you were doing
during the day.
And I know if I if I play a lot of
racquetball, I might even dream of it in
my sleep. So, whatever It And
Ecclesiastes says a dream comes through
the multitude of business.
So,
So, does that answer your question?
Yeah, sort of. Um so, we obviously Job,
I think it's Job 4:15. Okay. Uh it
appeared that he was awake and the
spirit came over him. And that's how I
was going to show whether like there's
been actual example in the Bible of
someone Satan actually appearing to or
giving a dream to someone.
Um you know, I can't think of any where
a person has a nightmare other than like
I said that story in uh
uh Genesis where it says a darkness came
over him. Now, I think that that
darkness actually was even divinely
inspired. God was about to tell Abraham
that his descendants would be captive in
a foreign land where they were going to
be oppressed 400 years.
So, that even may have come from the
Lord.
But um yeah, good question. I can't find
a an example is not at the tip of my
fingers of a nightmare.
But we know the devil can I think that
uh you know, the devil can certainly
influence our dreams. I know several
people that say they've woken up during
the night and they felt like someone was
trying to strangle them or
uh they have a you know, terrifying
experience.
So, yeah.
All right, let me see here.
Um
Michael is calling from Florida.
Michael, you're on the air with Bible
Answers Live.
Hello, Pastor Doug. Hi.
Hi. Yeah, so I was calling because
lately I've been um uh well, mostly
looking at um
work from different um uh Old Testament
and New Testament scholars.
And one thing that I've seen um a lot of
New Testament uh Old Testament scholars
say
is that um like a lot of the prophecies
that are traditionally said to refer to
things that are in the in the New
Testament, you know, I say traditionally
as in like in the tradition of like say
Protestant churches or even you know, in
Christian churches in modern
Christendom. Mhm. Um but those
prophecies were actually referring to
something else that was a little bit
more contemporary to the time of the
writers and and blah blah blah.
And usually when I going up in the
church, people have said that all these
things have a double interpretation.
They mean something toward the immediate
context of that contemporary time of the
writer. But they also uh refer to
something in the future. So, my question
is um how
did we ascertain that rule that
prophecies
in the Old Testament, I guess, have like
this
double interpretation. Like where did
where did we get that rule from? Cuz to
be honest, sometimes
it it seems a bit
arbitrary when we when when we invoke
that rule. And I I just want to know how
is it that we know that these prophecies
um have a double interpretation. Good.
Good good question. Um
First and best and safest way to know
is when the New Testament writers,
Matthew for example, often refers to an
Old Testament prophecy.
And uh
if for instance, he talks about Rachel
weeping for her children for they are
not.
Well, he's quoting an Old Testament
prophecy. He's applying it to the babies
in Jerusalem being uh Bethlehem being
slaughtered.
But that prophecy may also apply to when
the children of Israel were ransacked by
the Babylonians.
Um
you have the story of Jonah.
Jonah, Jesus said is a sign. Now, Jesus
is a good authority, you'd agree, I'm
sure. Jesus said Jonah is a sign of him.
No sign will be given of the Son of Man
but Jonah.
Well, Jonah was also a sign of the
Jewish nation.
They all viewed it that way that they
looked like they were done for when they
were carried off to Babylon and yet they
came out alive.
Uh so, they kind of saw them as because
of their rebellion, because they did not
prophesy to the pagan nations
that they went through a terrible storm
and um cuz they were neglecting their
duty.
But um
the other sailors on the boat and the
Ninevites were saved through Jonah.
The world is saved through the Jewish
nation delivering the scriptures.
But Jonah was a reluctant prophet and
the Jews often uh were stiff-necked. So,
Christians and Jews have seen a dual
application in Jonah. Let me give you
the best example in the Bible, one of
the best, I think.
In 1 Chronicles chapter 17,
David is thinking about building a
temple for the Lord.
And first Nathan the prophet says, "Go
for it, God is with you." Then God says,
"Go tell Nathan, you are not to build
the temple,
but your son is to build it." Now,
here's the verse. If you go to 1
Chronicles chapter 17 and you start with
um
Oh, let's see here, verse 11. "And it
will be when your days are fulfilled,
when you must go to be with your
fathers," meaning you die,
"that I'll set up your seed after you,
who will be of your sons. I will
establish his kingdom. He will build me
a house. I will establish his throne
forever."
Now, is that a prophecy about Solomon
who did build the temple, the son of
David? Or is that a prophecy about
Jesus, the son of David, who said,
"Destroy this temple and I will raise it
up"? Or is it both?
So, I think this is a great case where
you can argue easily that certainly
Solomon, David was thinking about a
literal temple and Solomon did build the
temple that David was praying about.
But Jesus is really the son of David who
built up the house of God. We are the
household of God. We are the body of
Christ.
Uh you see what I'm saying?
Yeah. The hard part of your question is
you said, "What is the rule?" So, you
know,
how do you discern
uh so it's not arbitrary?
I you know, I think the best thing is
you just look at the context. The best
thing is if you can find a New Testament
writer who gives a secondary
application,
then that would be that'd be I think the
the best way to know.
Um Mhm. So,
you know, God says, "I'm going to send a
prophet like
Elijah."
Jesus then says, "That was John the
Baptist." But then Jesus also says,
"John did come and Elijah did come and
Elijah will come." Jesus said that's a
dual prophecy.
Not only did Elijah come again, the
spirit and power of Elijah was on John
the Baptist. Christ said, "And he will
come," meaning before the second coming,
there's going to be another Elijah
message that will go. Mhm. So, when you
find a New Testament support,
then that's the best way to know, "Well,
they're using two applications for that
one prophecy." But there's other places
where I think it's obvious like the one
I read in Chronicles.
Mhm. So, I know deep deep subject. I
There's no easy answer for that. That's
a great question.
Yeah. All right, thank you, Michael.
Appreciate your call.
And uh that let me just tell my friends
here,
uh we have 8 minutes roughly in our
regular broadcast. We go off the air
with satellite first. Then I take a
couple of minutes more questions for
those who are on a land-based station or
you're watching on TV or Facebook. So,
don't go away at that point. And we've
got a number if you want to call in with
any of your questions or you can email
rather your questions. We take some
email questions at the very end of our
program
and do them in rapid succession. It's uh
BAL, what stands for Bible Answers Live.
Here's the address, BAL questions, BAL
questions at amazingfacts.org.
And that's how you can send those final
rapid-fire questions we cover
and uh in the end of the broadcast.
Talking next with um
Let me see here.
Oh, talk to Matthew in Canada. Matthew,
you're on the air with Bible Answers
Live.
Hi, Doug. Thanks for having me.
Uh question.
Before Jesus comes, how many generation
will be allowed to be living on Earth?
Or how many generation will you want
experience?
Well, when you say generation, are you
talking about like um
40 years? The Bible kind of tells us 40
years.
to
Yes, according to the Bible, 40 years
means a generation. So, How many of
those will you experience? How many of
those between the first coming and the
second?
Oh, well, no, it's already been clearly
more than four or five generations since
Jesus' first coming. Is that what you're
asking?
So, I'm saying, will any one individual
experience four or five generations?
No, not too many people. I think the
most is uh
three genera Well, you know, some people
live and see their great-grandchildren.
Uh a couple of rare individuals have
seen great-great-grandchildren.
But um it
I still don't know if I'm answering your
question.
No, I want to know how many generation
will there ever be before Jesus comes
the second time?
You know, no man knows the day or the
hour, Matthew, of Christ's coming.
So, you know, we don't know how many
generations. Jesus said, "This
generation will not pass away till these
things be fulfilled." He was talking
about the destruction of the temple.
That happened 40 years after Christ's
prediction. So, that was one generation,
just as Jesus said, "This generation
would not pass away."
How many generations from the first
coming to the second coming, the Bible
does not reveal.
So, I hope that helps a little bit.
All right, let's see here. Um
Um
Looking I get a couple time for a couple
more questions. Josiah in New York,
you're on the air with Bible Answers
Live.
Are you there? Sometimes people mute
their phones. Josiah, you are on the
air. There you go.
Good evening. How are you doing, sir?
Doing great. Thank you for calling.
Yes, I have a question based on the Book
of Revelation the first chapter verse
13 to
16. Okay. I don't want to read the um
W- when I read that verse,
and the question is
the Bible is clearly stated that
Jesus is a dark-skinned man. So why is
the church portraying Christ as a white
skinned man?
Well, here it says he's got skin like
bronze.
So are you wondering about what the what
the ethnic color of Jesus skin is in in
Revelation?
The book of Revelation speak the ethnic
color of of the Jesus Christ.
Well,
we can read here it says his eyes were a
flame of fire, his feet were like fine
brass as refined in a furnace.
Are you wondering So what is it the
heart of your question? I'm not sure.
The heart of my question is why
do religion pushes that Jesus is a so
called white man when the Bible teaches
that he's a dark skinned man?
All right. Well, Jesus was a Jew. Do you
have any problem with that?
I have no problem with that. But the
Jews of today is not the Jews of when
Christ walked around the earth.
Well, there's no question that you know
the Jewish people over the ages they've
been scattered around the world. There's
probably been some mixing.
Um but and you know by the way I'm half
Jewish anyway. My mother was Jewish.
But what? But the
the Bible does not dictate you're a Jew
by your mother. The When you go to the
book of number the numbers 1 verse 18 it
says you're a Jew by by your father.
That's the reason today you don't have a
tribe of Dana. Cuz all the tribes are
based on men not women. All right. All
right. Let me let me just jump in here
and ask you a question I think that's at
the heart of this. What makes a person a
Jew today?
According to the Bible what makes a
person a Jew they have to come from cuz
the the term Jew is from the from the
tribe Judah.
Well, I mean doesn't the
doesn't Paul say that if you are Christ
then you are Abraham's seed?
And doesn't the Bible say that he is not
a Jew that is one outwardly? He is a Jew
who is one inwardly.
And circumcision is not circumcision in
the flesh it's circumcision of the
spirit.
Yeah, but what what when you go on on
down in in in in the book of Galatians
Paul Paul explained to you who are the
Jews. He never
deviate from the true Jews. Is a person
saved Now again, I I want to reiterate
that I come from a Jewish background but
I don't believe a person is saved
because of their blood. God is no
respecter of persons. Do you believe
that a person is saved because they're
Jewish or because they have faith?
Yes. Yes, God is a respecter of person
because when you go in the book of woman
9 chapter verse 3 18 God said
Jacob that I love Esau that I hate. So
that's a respecter of person meaning God
hate
a particular group of people. And my
other question to you who is Esau today
cuz everybody want to be Jacob. Who is
Esau today and why the church is not
teaching the biblical nationality? Well,
first the verse the verse that you
quoted there Jacob I've loved and Esau
I've hated he's talking about Israel I
loved and the I hated because
of the decision
Well, it's because of the decisions that
Esau made to
go after the the the beans instead of
the birthright.
And so
Well, no that's what Genesis that's what
Genesis says. Yeah, but Paul Paul
elaborate. Paul said even before the
children were born the the God made his
decision
before they were even born knowing to
choose right or wrong. God no no God God
foretold what they would do before they
were born and then we saw that acted out
in their lives. But at the heart of this
you just said something you said God is
a respecter of person and Paul says God
is no respecter of persons. So Peter
actually says that. God But whoever
fears him from every people he loves.
If a person has faith in Jesus that's
what saves them.
What does that mean that Jacob that I
love Esau that I hate? That meaning God
do have a particular group of people
that he love. All right.
Josiah, I
I don't want to be rude. I have to mute
you just because I got 38 seconds left
and I want to be able to sign off.
I I hope and you're welcome to call
again and we can finish this discussion
but the time's not going to allow it.
Hey friends, I want to
give a special reminder to those who are
listening on satellite radio right now
that we'd encourage you to participate
in Revelation's final warning. If you're
watching on TV they may put that to add
there it is up again. Special program
begins this Friday evening. You can tune
in on Facebook. You can also watch on
Amazing Facts Television. It'll be on
the Doug Batchelor Facebook page the
Amazing Facts YouTube channel. We're
going to be talking about the messages
that go to the world
Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before. Bible
Answers Live is produced by Amazing
Facts International a faith based
ministry located in Granite Bay,
California.
Okay, there you have it. We are back
friends and for those of you who have
stayed by you're enduring to the end.
We're going to be talking about some
questions that have come in. All right.
First question, when Satan is deceiving
some people at the end of times when he
is telling everybody he is Jesus can
Satan duplicate Jesus pierced hands?
Well, I think he can. You know, he's
called 2 Corinthians chapter 11 says
Satan
is can be transformed into an angel of
light. He can create illusions. So if
he's impersonating Christ if he wants to
impersonate a Christ that's got some
kind of scars in his hands
that would probably be very impressive.
What Satan cannot reproduce is coming in
the clouds of glory. Uh Jesus never
touches the ground again when he comes.
It says we are caught up to meet him in
the air. So anybody walking around on
the ground that says that they are
Christ um they're either demonic or or
deluded. But do not follow any false
Christ.
Um let me see here. It says Jesus is now
in heaven at the right hand of God and
no longer active on earth. He left us a
comforter who is active. So we ask Jesus
into our hearts or is it the Holy Spirit
that comes into our hearts?
Christ comes into our hearts through the
Holy Spirit. Jesus said that I'm going
and it's expedient that I go the Holy
Spirit will come and then he promises I
am with you everywhere you go. How is he
with us? Through the person of God the
spirit we have the presence of Christ.
Jesus says he will declare all things to
you.
The spirit gives us the very presence of
Christ. You will sense Jesus with you in
God the spirit cuz God is one.
Uh
Show me one unequivocal or equivocal
sentence in the Bible where Jesus says I
am God and we must worship him. Well,
there is no verse where he says I am God
we must worship him. But it does tell
about people worshiping him. You read in
Hebrews where it says even the angels
worship him. The God The Bible says in
the 10 Commandments we are to worship
only God Jesus must be God.
The Bible says only God knows the
thoughts of men's hearts yet Jesus knew
people's thoughts. Jesus must be God.
The Bible says there is one God and
savior. Jesus is our savior. Jesus must
be God. And you can read when he rose
from the dead he said all hail and the
disciples held him by the feet and
worshiped him. He received that worship
unless he was God they were breaking the
commandments of God. So yes, Jesus is
God. He said in John chapter 8 I am
before Abraham was I am. That's the same
name that Moses used or God gave to
Moses rather.
All right.
Is there let me say is there a verse
that says God gives us the freedom of
choice?